well one topic in the coalition talks to
form a new government here in germany is
the legalization of cannabis products
all three parties are in favor of a
regulated system for cultivation trade
and sale german pharmaceutical companies
are also hoping for a boost from this
will we soon see cues like this in
germany too
when cannabis was first legalized in
canada three years ago many customers
were eager to make the first legal
purchase of marijuana i just wanted to
be here
i think it's like a big deal it's like a
historical moment right
today the legal cannabis industry in
canada posts more than 2 billion euros
in sales annually the government closely
monitors cultivation and sales
what about germany most of the cannabis
here is sold on the black market that
means no quality control with organized
crime collecting the profits the
incoming government wants to change that
and canada is a role model at least for
the greens the german pharmaceuticals
industry is also expecting a boost from
legalization
it acquires most of its medicinal
cannabis from abroad for example from
this greenhouse in denmark plants grown
here are required to have a consistent
psychoactive effect now medical cannabis
is already being sold on prescription in
german pharmacies
in the first half of 2021 alone german
doctors prescribed 90 million euros
worth of cannabis to patients for four
years now it has been sold to patients
with chronic pain or epilepsy
so far only three pharmaceutical
companies in germany are allowed to
cultivate cannabis and only outdoors
behind thick concrete walls but sales of
medicinal cannabis are on the rise so
far most of it has been imported from
canada
and for more on this i'm joined by
johannes gallowa he's executive partner
import and distribution of medical
cannabis at gikka pharma in cologne good
to have you with us so we just heard
that the pharmaceutical companies are
also looking forward to a legalization
of cannabis how would your business
profit from that
good morning monica thank you for uh
being on the program so um there are
very exciting times at the moment to
follow these debates and um so for us
the main
topic is how will cannabis be dispensed
in the future and for us as a company
the priority is to make
cannabis and cannabinoids accessible to
the biggest number of patients in
general so we hope that the total market
size will increase and when we follow
the role model in canada there is a
potential to have up to one million
patients and users in germany um in a
relatively short time if legalization or
further um
yeah program is due to happen okay so
there's big scope and of course we're
not just talking about patients here but
just normal consumers who uh like to to
have a bit of weed in their spare time
and germany currently post 230 million
euros in the sale of medical cannabis
that's every year if cannabis was also
available as a legal stimulant then
sales could increase by a factor of 17
some analysts say we're talking about
almost 4 billion euros annually now
given those numbers what are german
authorities waiting for that's a lot of
money
so that's true those are very big
numbers um but when we consider that
cannabis until 2019
has been
classified as a class iv drug similar to
heroin and cocaine with no
pharmaceutical or therapeutic use in
2019 all of this changed and
we have a class 1 classification now
which is granting cannabis
pharmaceutical use and now we are taking
big steps
in already debating a further
liberalization and even a legalization
in germany so for me this is a very good
starting point and
who knows what the new government will
bring on the table in fact right so are
there any downsides any doubts any
warnings you can share with us
so in my opinion um as a recommendation
i would say that the the government
should listen very carefully to all the
stakeholders that they want to involve
in their programs um beginning with the
um importers the producers but also who
should dispense it uh if it will be the
pharmacist um they should be on the
table as well right and basically we
have to create the
market environment it's it's listen to
the experts that's what you're telling
us johannes galway executive partner
import and distribution of medical
cannabis at gigafarmer thank you so much